[Music]
back now at 7 30 on cbs mornings and as
we prepare to mark the anniversary of
the january 6th assault on the u.s
capitol we are hearing for the first
time from a top intelligence official in
the capitol police three days before the
attack she wrote an intelligence
assessment sounding the alarm about
potential violence at the capitol
much of which actually came to pass so
why were her warnings not acted upon
chris van cleave is on capitol hill with
an interview you will only see on cbs
mornings and it's a good one chris good
morning to you
good morning julie farnam had been on
the job just 72 days when rioters
stormed the capitol on january 6th but
it was this report she gave to capitol
police leadership three days earlier on
january third that's become a glaring
example of intelligence slipping through
the cracks
do you feel that that you and your team
bear responsibility for what happened on
the 6th no i don't i think we provided
the information i think we did an
excellent job julie farnam is the acting
intelligence director for the capitol
police for weeks leading up to january 6
she says her team had been gathering
intelligence indicating violence was
likely we knew there were going to be
thousands of protesters and we knew
there were going to be extremists there
and i knew things were not going to be
good that day cbs news obtained her
final intelligence assessment dated
january 3rd bottom line it read
protesters plan to be armed then there's
this on page 13 her team's overall
analysis which raised concerns about
permits given to groups affiliated with
stop the steel known to attract white
supremacists and militia members who
actively promote violence it warned
trump supporters see january 6 as the
last opportunity to overturn the results
of the presidential election this sense
of desperation and disappointment may
lead to more of an incentive to become
violent and unlike previous protests
congress itself is the target on the
sixth there was no other agency in the
federal government except the capitol
police that wrote a comprehensive
assessment and report that outlined the
violence that was expected that day how
do you justify the performance to some
of the folks that look at the end result
on january 6th
which was an utter failure
i think in some regards on january 6 our
intelligence division was an island we
bear some responsibility for that so
that the warnings were there they just
didn't get where they needed to go at
the end of the day
that's my understanding once i sent it
up to my leadership i didn't have
control over where it went last february
congress asked yogananda pittman who
became acting chief after the
insurrection about the january third
assessment although we knew the
likelihood for violence by extremists no
credible threat indicated that tens of
thousands would attack the u.s capitol
pittman is now back in the job she held
on january 6 overseeing all intelligence
operations for the capitol police
including julie farnham's team i think
that there will be people that see this
interview and wonder
should anyone who is involved with
intelligence before january 6th still be
involved with intelligence after january
6. i can't speak to the personnel issues
should you still be running the team yes
i should be because i largely wrote that
assessment and i'm the one who has been
working tirelessly every single day
since i've come on board to right the
ship the department declined to make
pittman available for an interview
current chief tom manger took over the
force in july why wasn't that
intelligence acted on i can't answer
that question because i was not here on
january 3rd nor january 6th but i can
tell you this that the way intelligence
was shared the way it was disseminated
needed vast improvement and so today
that kind of intelligence would be acted
on we're in a posture now where we're
not taking any chances what
responsibility does the department bear
for what happened that day i think that
overall the department bears the
majority of the responsibility i mean
the organization let the men and women
of this police department down they had
the intelligence the intelligence was
right but the leadership i think failed
to rank and foul members and they failed
congress congressman tim ryan chairs the
committee overseeing the capitol police
do you feel like the department has made
the necessary changes to prevent a
repeat of that day i'm not concerned
that there's going to be another
insurrection at the capitol we've take
taken some positive steps in the right
direction but there's a hell of a long
way for us to go over the last year the
department has opened its first ever
field offices the intelligence unit has
doubled in size and improved the
training of its analysts in an effort to
ensure something like the sixth never
happens again
is it hard for an intel person who's
delivered a report
much of it came to fruition
to then see the result on january 6th of
course it is i mean that was a difficult
day to see what happened i was listening
to the police radio when that was
happening and to hear
the officer's screams
and everything that happened that day
it's very difficult
chief manger is set to testify for the
first time before congress he will tell
the senate rules committee that january
6 exposed key deficiencies in the
capitol police and operational planning
staffing equipment and of course
intelligence he will lay out the ongoing
efforts to fix those deficiencies nate
chris thank you what we do know is the
information was shared
it just wasn't spread properly and then
passed up to the i also know that none
of this
undermines the heroism of the capitol
police rank and file who were there
trying to defend the building well the
resources that they were provided
it's so frustrating to hear that they
had access to the information it wasn't
acted upon i can only imagine how
frustrated she is and i get it gets to
me too when you see that police officer
screaming the way he was screaming right
but you would think it's not possible
what happened at the capitol that it
happened i still when i look at the
video i still can't believe what i'm
watching a year later we are better than
this yes it's americans against
americans
yes it does like i said tony in hopes
that it doesn't happen again yeah that's
for sure